what's going on with Boy Scouts Adam
look at this up so Boy Scouts look it up
on just Google Boy Scouts
it's a everyone knows a Boy Scout is we
actually have a lot of non-american
listeners right I just remember that
look at me I grew up in America but I
didn't do Boy Scouts so I have a very
loose understanding okay how about Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts when you're in
between the ages of 8 and maybe 18 it's
just like a after-school program and a
weekend program and for Boy Scouts it
helps you become a man it was it's an
organization that's been around probably
since the late 1800s it was rude to do
it no I played sports inside my joke was
you do Boy Scouts no I do sports so Mike
my mom and dad made me choose between
ice hockey and Boy Scouts I did hockey
but a lot of my friends did like when I
grew up I grew up Catholic so it's like
altar boy Boy Scouts or how sports
that's like what you choose and so you
got a bullet yeah I got all my teeth I
got my teeth knocked out from hockey but
at least I didn't get that other [__]
and so Boy Scouts and Girl Scouts it's
basically when you're a youth it's a
youth group it teaches you how to be a
man how to be a woman all right we got
knots and sell cookies and all that good
[__] it's rooted in religion though
which is controversial now that
religions not as popular in America Boy
Scouts what happened they recently got
sued because of molesting boys is that
right okay it's not just sued once like
there's just like a litany of lawsuits
and they were like what are we gonna do
with all this they basically are
declaring bankruptcy yeah it was a huge
deal and so I was curious and so here's
something that's interesting about Boy
Scouts and Girl Scouts and any nonprofit
all their financials are available yeah
just look up annual letter annual report
Boy Scout yeah any nonprofit you can go
and see everything to see how they spend
their money what they own it's really
cool and so I looked up Boy Scouts and
let me give you some stats here so they
had a 1.5 billion dollars in assets
membership right now they have around 2
million members that's at an all-time
low in the 60 70s and 80s it was all the
way up to 6 or 7 million members they
make hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue
think in 18 it was 200 million dollars
in sales most of that revenue came from
fees so you pay a fee actually Adam look
up how much it cost how much does it
cost to join Boy Scouts so and then they
also make money from some merchandise
and everything but the majority of their
revenue comes from fees and then they
make between 50 and 80 million dollars a
year in contributions and gifts it's
cost $60 a year so they receive 50 to 80
million in gifts or they give receive
receive donations yeah and each Q 50
million what are they spending on here
yeah so HQ includes so HQ and
programming and all that stuff so
basically their HQ oh so they have two
million members so they have offices
where their headquarters is and then
people volunteer to lead troops and you
probably give them a little bit of money
like an allowance or something like that
like a small stipend right and then they
pay for all the programming so maybe
kids gotta raise money to go camping and
I think Boy Scouts will contribute a
little bit of that so what's interesting
here for you is it I'll tell you
business ideas with the business and
here's why so Boy Scouts I'm gonna
compare Boy Scouts the Girl Scouts and
then I'm gonna show you the differences
in financials and then I'm gonna compare
it to one other group that I think is
actually doing it right and here's what
I think I think that you could these new
clubs these young men and young women
clubs particularly young men clubs I
think could be massive and can exist in
today's world and so and you wonder what
Boy Scouts base biggest expenses
insurance insurance they pay a hundred
and twenty million dollars for insurance
they pay a lot of money because they're
taking kids out into the wild yeah and
that was wild to me that's the biggest
cost okay so now let's compare this to
Girl Scouts this is timely because Girl
Scout cookies just got released Girl
Scouts they sell eight hundred million
dollars a year in Girl Scout cookies
unbelievable [__] crazy right crazy
seventy-five percent of that revenue is
there that's how much they paid twenty
five take they pay 25% to the bakeries
and I think it actually might at this
point own the bakery bakeries yeah and
then so that's their take the majority
of that revenue goes to the truck the
troops is they call it troops chapters
or chapters and that pays for
they do they give young women
scholarships they just teach them how to
be young women they do all types of
programming and things like that and so
here's a few ways in which they're
different thirty six million dollars in
dues so way less their membership Girl
Scouts is about the same and they
receive roughly ten percent of the gifts
back that Boy Scout donations yeah so
but Girl Scouts is a way better business
right now I don't I'm not trying to
advocate that these types of things
necessarily should be for-profit
businesses there is a place for
nonprofit but let's just say that we
want to make this a for-profit here's
what I would do yeah
Boy Scouts there they're [__] the
reason they're [__] is this whole
regardless if you're religious or not
religion in America is not as popular
it's so very popular but it's declining
right it's not it's not growing it's not
growing and Boy Scouts has a very
religious component about it extremely
and America like we don't have like Wars
going on right now and when you turn 18
and like could join the military morale
or two or the one Korean War Vietnam or
even up until it late early 90s with the
Iraqi war I mean there was there was a
little bit of a rite of passage for a
man you know you get a job you have kids
or you go to war like there's like this
like right a passage that allows that
it's like alright you're you're the man
you're a man now we don't really have
that now right and I think that's
actually a huge problem in young men's
lives women have it a little bit because
biologically they get their period I
mean that's like you are by definition
of a woman men that's why the whole
thing of men you could be like a 25 year
old boy or a 35 year old boy like
especially in Silicon Valley there's
these guys that they dress like kids
still and they don't act like men and so
I actually think that there could be a
rite of passage a rite of passage is
some type of group of like you're a boy
we're gonna we're gonna help you become
a man but you're thinking past the Boy
Scout age you're talking about 18 no I
think about younger no no I I think that
you can learn that from age 8 to 18
slowly gotcha and so the best member
would you do it
so the best membership group I've ever
seen and I've done a lot of research on
this is a ARP okay and AARP what it is
is once you become sixty years old
I actually signed up for this because I
want to see the marketing I was really
interested in this there once you become
sixty years old they mail you a thing an
AARP card and they go you're in and
you're like I'm in like yeah you just
turned they find out how they works with
the post office and they find out when
you're turned 60 years old they send you
a card that day nice and you get your
card and AARP has 38 million members
it's really cheap to become an AARP
member like 50 bucks maybe less but
maybe $18 it's really cheap depending on
the tier you get and so but AARP makes
one point six billion dollars in revenue
so where's all that money coming from
it's not coming from fees it's all
coming from the backend so once you
become an AARP member they go alright
they partner with I think United
insurance and a few others and they make
what is it what's it up there a billion
dollars a year from affiliates meaning
you're now old we're gonna give you a
discount on some insurance because we're
pooled everyone together you should use
the United insurance it's the best one
and that's when they get they get their
billion dollar cut it's a discount Club
so as you as a member you pay a low fee
you make your money back in discounts
pretty much from day one they make their
money by getting the vendors to offer
them a cut for all these customers that
they can drive to them yes and yes this
is brilliant the first time you told me
about this you were talking about can we
do this for Millennials yeah I wanted to
do this for the hustle and I was like
why didn't you do this I've always
thought this was your best idea oh yeah
you must have learned something along
the way that made you less bullish on it
what was that I'm not less bullish on it
but I'll explain that I know sorry I am
a little less bullish but I still think
it could be great
so AARP it's like one of the it's might
be the one of the largest lobbying
groups ever so if you want to become
president you have to like appeal so
they appeal to AARP 38 million members
you got to like you know elderly we're
gonna make sure your area yeah and and
AARP is so big they have like - what
does it say oh sorry
three three and a half billion dollar
they have a hedge fund I mean like this
is like a like this is how much cash
they have and so when you think about
what makes like a group like this
passionate it's really similar to a cult
right so I think what you need is you
need like a common bond so what brings
you guys together so for Girl Scouts
it's you're a young girl yeah for Boy
Scouts you're a young boy
for AARP it's we're all 60 and so it's
like we have to figure out how to get
through this together
you need an enemy I think oh so a good
example of a really good group like this
is the NRA right and so the NRA like if
they say they're gonna take our guns
they're gonna raise so much money off
that so you need like an enemy another
thing is you need a leader like a face
and so NRA had that it was a Wayne
LaPierre was the leader and like it's
I'm not even a gun guide and I know his
name and their other one one was um the
famous actor Heston Charlton Heston and
he had that phrase from my goal my cold
dead hands like you're gonna take my
that's the leader so you need that
leader and then you need this mentality
of us versus everyone and we're the
underdogs and they're gonna come at us
Boy Scouts and Girl Scouts actually
could have a little bit with that
Christian vibe but I don't know how you
do it without the Christian vibe and
then finally you need like rituals Girl
Scouts and Boy Scouts all have that they
have like the pledge you know and I
don't know AARP does but when I'm
thinking about this I totally think that
you could create recreate some of these
I think it would take a long ass time it
would take a long-ass time I don't think
you need all those things I think those
are all like boosters there's all
strengthen the whole thing and I think
they come over time but I don't think
they're prereqs right I don't think the
pre-requirements
you don't like I don't know who's the
leader of who's the the charismatic
leader of Boy Scouts I don't know like
maybe there was one maybe it wasn't well
I agree with you you don't need it but I
think your point here is proving my
point which is they're declining and
there is a sure but I guess like they
got to a certain size and mass so what I
think you just have to do is sort of
align a common set of people who have a
sort of similar desire or desired
lifestyle whether it's like you know
Christian faith combined with you know
learning life skills and will and being
out in nature right Boy Scouts and and
actually I think you can have this like
Christian conservative group that would
can crush it right because what I do
every morning is I go to opposite news
sites
I go to HuffPo and then I go to bright
part Breitbart you know that is yeah
okay they have a smaller audience I bet
than HuffPo every article has 5,000
comments right super engaged yeah so
there's a big enough group there right
so I think as long as you tap into any
lifestyle that people care about I think
you can create a group like this and so
you have the sort of right combination
of like benefits and like programming
and rituals all those things I think are
good and helpful I also think that these
can happen when I saw Boy Scouts was
going out of business I went looked up
biggest Boy Scout competitors and they
were all Boy Scout clones so they were
all faith-based nature programming for
young men and it's like okay well it
just seems like there are other people
who will want who have the same job to
be done as they say like who want the
same outcome but they put less value in
let's say the religion component
religious component or maybe it's less
value in the nature component like they
tell you my sister runs a program she
has to daycare so she has to like
childcare facilities that are like Ian
home childcare facility so she took a
she took a house she turned it into a
daycare and or a preschool so one's up
one's for younger kids one to preschool
so she wanted to do a third the
permitting was going really slow and so
she bought this house but could the
permits going slow so she did kind of a
genius thing she created this program
called nature kids she's like okay I
can't do the prep I can't get the permit
for my in-home thing they're just taking
six months but I have this huge wait
list of people who want you know their
kids to be a part of something what if I
made a nature-based program so she
created nature kids she now needs no
permitting they just go around through
like the you know the parks and the the
nature I hear they do they like learn
about plants and animals and they do
little exercises and they do outdoor
painting and tree climbing and they're
just out all day and parents love it
because they're like yeah I want my kid
to be out and not you know sort of
cooped up or looking at a screen or all
this stuff and so I want my kid out
there in nature learning these skills
there's no religious component to it she
has a wait list out the door now it can
scale like she could just create a
franchise out of this like this nature
kids thing is like a tiny speck but it's
a comparable I think to what Boy Scouts
is providing you know providing a
certain so here's the two trends that
this is capitalizing on the first is I
don't know about you I bet I bet you
fallen asleep catagories me but tech
executives people who have grown up with
the internet now and phones do you not
want their kids do not what their kids
do in this [__] I'm the same way I
bought this thing that locks potato
chips in a seal like a time Locker right
occasion eight and I put my phone in
there
okay so like I will I don't want my kids
using phones and stuff like that so
we're this turns to be a bigger as you
and me sir I haven't yet burgers like
yeah we're gonna limit this to 40
minutes a day or so right and so we're
gonna see that happen the second trend
that I don't know if it's trend but I do
think it's actually needed is we have to
have artificial we have to actually
start creating these things that allow
young women and young men to become yeah
men right character building yeah in in
and I've seen it too or I've seen these
things now for grown men where you can
pay a fee mankind project is super
popular and they're awesome I employ
reduce I went to an all guys Catholic
High School which was pretty good
because we got to they helped us evolve
and grow and everything but I so wish
that I had my father wasn't like very
hands-on I wish I had more of like a
hands-on like alright son here's you
gotta do this you treat people this way
you do it like you wanna mean and I
think that that can actually be way more
popular
[Music]